really hard to look back on it now and
go what on Earth happened it's 2020 and
Prince Harry and his American Wife Megan
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex are
leaving the UK we've just finished
uh two weeks
our final push our last stint of Royal
engagements
it's just four years after they first
met the level of
[Music]
hate that has been stirred up in the
last three years especially against my
wife and and my son is my mom outside
with Archie I'm generally concerned for
the safety of my family
the four children the first of six
episodes of this Netflix series goes
back to Harry's childhood we could look
at this camera please
it was how he felt the glare of the
media and the effect it had on his
mother Princess Diana who died in a car
crash while being chased by press
photographers
series Harry says members of his family
questioned why Megan should be protected
from the press the difference he told
them was the element of race the way
tabloid newspapers used racist tropes
when talking about Meghan Markle has
been well documented
but there was according to the sussexes
also racism from within the royal family
something the families denied it led to
a breakdown in relations most notably
with Harry's father King Charles and his
brother Prince William and contributed
to Megan feeling suicidal for a long
time people like myself have been
talking about the Insidious nature of
the racism in Britain and we've seen it
so many times like reflected to us in
the British press and we've been told
that we imagined it or we're being too
sensitive what this does is it forces a
conversation about race and racism and
the class system within Britain all the
interviews in the Netflix series were
done by August this year the month
before Queen Elizabeth died it's very
much the couple's account and the royal
family says it's not commenting on it
the worsening relationship between the
sussexes and Buckingham palaces and
institution dominated Royal coverage
here in Britain during the last years of
Queen Elizabeth's life with Prince
Harry's father now on the throne you
might think there'd be a chance for a
reset this new documentary suggests it's
still complicated Nadeem Barber Al
Jazeera London